ازمه اخرى تعصف في اوروبا بعيدا عن الغاز
انها الاضطرابات وتداعياتها فحم الاضرابات
لا تزال تجتاح مختلف ربوع بريطانيا والدور
جاء ايضا على دول اوروبيه اخرى اخر
المنظمين للحمله عمال الخدمه العامه
والتجاريه الذين يخوضون اضرابهم الاول يوم
الجمعه المقبل ويستمر
لثلاثه ايام على ان يخوضوا اضرابا ثانيا
نهايه السنه ما ينبئ بفوضه في حركه
الرحلات الجويه على اعتبار انا موظفي
مراقبه منافذ الحدود معنيون ايضا
بالاضراره هذا هو ستؤدي هذه الاضرابات الى
تاثر الحركه في العديد من المطارات في
البلاد في توقيت حساسه من السنه التزامنا
مع اعياد الميلاد فصدرت هيئه الطيران
المدني في بريطانيا تحذيرا للمسافرين بشان
احتماليه التاخير في ايام الاضراب وسبق
عند ذكر صحيفه تايمز ان شركات الطيران
ربما تخطط اعداد المسافرين بنسبه 30 يعني
في حال شهدت المطارات ازدحاما لا طاقه لها
به من بين اكثر الاضرابات اثاره للجدل
وجذبا للاهتمام اضراب عمال التمريض في
مناطق مختلفه او الممرضين في مناطق مختلفه
في بريطانيا مطالبيننا برفع الاجور فرق
التمرين خاضت اضرابا ثانيا يمتد لاربع 24
ساعه رغم مطالب الحكومه بالتراجع عن هذا
الاضراب لما في ذلك من تعريض لحياه الناس
او حياه المرضى للخطر تحديدا يبدو بان
الطرفين
او لا سيران في اتجاه الوصول الى ارضيه
للتفاهم ما يعني بان التصعيد قد يتواصل
وفي احدث رد لها قالت الحكومه البريطانيه
انها لن تقدم المزيد من الاموال لاطقم
التمريض والاسعافات من اجل انهاء
الاضطرابات من جهته قال رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني رئيس السوناك ان الوقت لا يسمح
بمناقشات مساله الاجور واشارك اكثر من
100,000 ممرض وممرضه من انجلترا وويلز
ايرلندا الشماليه في هذه الادراجات
[موسيقى]
معنا من لندن مراسل العربيه مصطفى زارو
مصطفى اهلا بك قبل ان اسالك عن الممرضين
واضرابهم والى اين وصل بودي ان يتسائل عن
المطارات هل هناك اجراءات قد تتخذها
الحكومه البريطانيه لمواجهه هذه الاضرابات
خاصه في هذه الفتره الحساسه من السنه
وتوقيت اعياد الميلاد وراس السنه
ما سمعناه وحتى الان من من طرف الحكومه
وان احبرت المسافرين خلال هذه الفتره فتره
4 ايام على مرتين ابتداءا من يوم الجمعه
لمده اربعه ايام ومن ثم يعودون لاربعه
ايام اخرى ضباط حرس الحدود سيقضون هذا
الادراك يعني بسبب المطالبه برفع الاجور
وايضا مواجهه تكلفه المعيشه التي شهيدناها
في في الاشهر او خاصه في هذا العام همم
الحليب بسبب الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا
بالاضافه الى نسبه التضخم التي سجلت في
هذا البلد لاعلى المستويات منذ اربعه عقود
وبالتالي ليست هناك حتى هذه اللحظه اي
بوادر بان هذا هذه الاضرابات خاصه فيما
يتعلق بحرس الحدود انهم همم يعني سيعدنون
عنها هناك سته سته مطارات
سيتم الاستعانه من موظفين المدنيين وايضا
همم عناصر من الجيش البريطاني للعمل همم
تشغيل الخطوط الاماميه لهذه الاماكن وايضا
هي قطاعات حيويه جدا ولكن الكل ان ينتظر
مائده سيتم يعني تنفيذ هذا الاضراب وهو
اضراب ضخم كما يعني كما كما كما نعرف
بالاضافه الى ايضا الاضرابات الاخرى وكما
ذكرت همم
اطقم التمريض وهو اكبر اضراب تشهده البلاد
في قطاع خدمات
الوطنيه بالاضافه الى اطقم الاسعاف يعني
القطاعين سواء التمريض او حتى في المطارات
وحرس الحدود الحكومه البريطانيه هل اتخذت
قرارها بانها لن تدفع المزيد من الاموال
او حتى الدخول في مفاوضات معهم هل اغلق
هذا الباب
في اخر تعليق من الحكومه ومن ريشه هناك
الذي يعني مثلا امام لجنه برلمانيه لاول
مره منذ ان حظ
بمنصب رئيس الوزراء قال بان يحترم هذا
القطار قطاع الصحه ولكن كانت هناك لجنه هي
التي حددت رفع الاجور بنسبه تقريبا 5%
بينما تطالب النقابه بما يقارب بين 17 في
المئه ويجيب التذكير بانها نسبه التضخم
يعني اقل من 11% وبالتالي تقول الحكومه ان
ليس لديها اموال تسعه مليارات جنيه هذه
الاجور وهذا سيؤدي الى مزيد من التدخل
بالتالي كان احدى الاولويات ليه ريشه هناك
عندما تقاليد السلطه وهو السيطره على
التضخم ولا يريد ان اا تزيد هذه النسبه
التي ستؤثر على حياه الناس بشكل عام
همم شكرا جزيلا لمراسل العربيه مصطفى زارو
كنت معنا من لندن